THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
♪ ♪
NOW DESPITE THEIR BIG GAINS IN
THE HOUSE AND THE MIDTERMS,
DEMOCRATS STILL MAY NOT GET IT.
THEY HAVE A NEW LINE.
THEY'VE BEEN TESTING IT OUT.
READY FOR THIS?
THEY ARE NOW THE SMARTEST PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM WHO HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS, EVEN IF YOU ARE TOO
STUPID TO UNDERSTAND IT.
SPEAKER ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE, AS DEMOCRATS, HAVE A REALLY
HARD TIME IS CONNECTING TO
PEOPLE'S HEARTS INSTEAD OF HERE.
WE ARE REALLY GOOD AT SHOVING
OUT ALL THE INFORMATION THAT
TOUCHES PEOPLE HERE BUT NOT
HERE.
WE DEMOCRATS KNOW SO MUCH, THAT
IS TRUE.
BUT WE HAVE THE KIND OF
INTELLIGENCE, HOW SMART WE ARE,
SO WE HAVE A TENDENCY TO BE VERY
LEFT BRAIN.
>> Laura: LEST YOU THINK THIS
IS SOME ISOLATED IDEA,
ALL RIGHT, THAT WE ARE JUST SO
SMART WE HAVE TROUBLE CONNECTING
WITH YOU.
IT'S ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT IS
SHARED FAIRLY WIDELY.
AND TWO OF THE LATEST
FORBEARERS, BY THE WAY, OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> DO YOU REALLY THINK
DONALD TRUMP HAS THE TEMPERAMENT
TO BE COMMANDER IN CHIEF?
IMAGINE HIM IN THE OVAL OFFICE
FACING A REAL CRISIS.
>> HE JUST SAYS, I'M GOING TO
NEGOTIATE A BETTER DEAL.
WHAT MAGIC WAND DO YOU HAVE?
AND USUALLY THE ANSWER IS, HE
DOESN'T HAVE AN ANSWER.
>> THIS OFFICE HAS A WAY OF
WAKING YOU UP.
HIS POSITIONS OR PREDISPOSITIONS
THAT DON'T MATCH UP WITH
REALITY, HE WILL FIND SHAKEN UP
PRETTY QUICK.
>> Laura: OKAY.
THE OBVIOUS IMPLICATION BEING
THAT DONALD TRUMP AND THOSE
AMERICANS WHO VOTED FOR HIM ARE
JUST A BUNCH OF DUMB ROOMS.
NOW LET'S FACE IT, WHEN TRUMPED
WON IN 2016 -- YOU CAN SEE OBAMA
THERE, STILL SHELL-SHOCKED IN
NOVEMBER OF 2016.
TRUMP EMBARRASSED A LOT OF THE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS, CONSULTANTS,
THE POLLSTERS, THE STRATEGISTS,
ALL THE BIG THINKERS, AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT CLASS.
SO FEELING SUDDENLY DIMINISHED,
THEY LASHED OUT AT TRUMP,
BELITTLING HIS INTELLIGENCE.
>> THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T READ.
WE KNOW THAT.
>> ISN'T IT REMARKABLE
REMARKABLE HOW LITTLE CONFIDENCE
DONALD TRUMP'S OWN LAWYERS
HAVING HIM?
THEY THINK HE IS TOO STUPID TO
STAND -- SIT ACROSS THE TABLE
WITH ROBERT MUELLER?
>> ALMOST CAVEMAN-LIKE.
REALLY IS.
QUITE FRANKLY.
>> A MAN WITHOUT CURIOSITY, A
MAN WHO DOESN'T READ, AND IT'S A
MAN WITH AN ATTENTION SPAN OF A
RABBIT FLY.
>> Laura: OKAY.
THAT IS GOING BACK.
[LAUGHS]
THEY SAID SIMILAR THINGS BY THE
WAY ABOUT REAGAN, UNTIL HE DIED,
OF COURSE, AND THEN THEY ALL
PRETENDED THAT THEY NEVER SAID
ANY OF THE MEAN STUFF THEY
SAID ABOUT HIM FOR HIS TWO
TERMS IN OFFICE.
LIBERALS CLAIM TO BE FOR THE
LITTLE GUY.
THEY ARE THE CHAMPIONS OF THE
AVERAGE PERSON.
BUT THEY ARE REALLY ELITIST
SNOBS THAT HARD.
MAUREEN DOWD, "NEW YORK TIMES"
COLUMNIST, USED TO WRITE THESE
PIECES MOCKING THE CULTURAL AND
CULINARY TASTES OF BUSH 41 AND
BARBARA.
HE ATE PORK RINDS IN THE TWO OF
THEM WATCHED THINGS LIKE
"AMERICA'S FUNNIEST HOME VIDEOS"
ON TV ON SUNDAY NIGHTS.
THE SUBJECT WAS ALWAYS, LOOK AT
THE BUSHES.
IVY LEAGUE BLUE BLOODS BUT STILL
UNSOPHISTICATED, AND FRANKLY,
NOT ALL THAT SMART.
BUT HERE'S A NEWS FLASH FOR
EVERYBODY.
NO ONE WHO BECOMES PRESIDENT IS
DUMB.
ESPECIALLY NOT TRUMP, WHO
MANAGED TO BEAT NOT ONE, BUT TWO
POLITICAL DYNASTIES TO ENACT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
REMEMBER ALL THE DIRE
PREDICTIONS MADE BY THE
POLITICAL AND BUSINESS SAVANTS
ABOUT A TRUMP PRESIDENCY?
>> IF THE UNLIKELY EVENT HAPPENS
AND TRUMP WINS, YOU WILL SEE A
MARKET CRASH OF HISTORIC
PROPORTIONS.
>> IN THE EVENT DONALD WINS, I
HAVE NO DOUBT IN MY MIND, THE
MARKET TANKS.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS MOVING US
TOWARD WORLD WAR III.
>> THE LACK OF DIPLOMATIC AND
SERIOUS ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY, IN
MY VIEW, HAS US SLIDING TOWARD
WAR BY NEXT SUMMER.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
WE COULD DO THIS ALL NIGHT LONG.
THAT IS REALLY ENTERTAINING.
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR ALLIES IMPLY
THAT THEY HAVE A MONOPOLY ON
INTELLIGENCE AND BRAINPOWER.
BUT IF THAT'S TRUE, WHY HAVE
THEY SCREWED THINGS UP SO BADLY
WHEN THEY HAVE THE CHANCE TO FIX
THEM?
WHILE TRUMP IDENTIFIES THE
THREAT, FOR INSTANCE, POSED BY
CHINA AND HAS CHALLENGED THEM,
WHO CAN FORGET BILL CLINTON
PUSHING FOR CHINA'S SUCCESS OR
LESS ON THE WORLD STAGE WITH HIS
MISGUIDED WTO PUSH?
>> DISAGREEMENT IS A GOOD DEAL
FOR AMERICA.
OUR PRODUCTS WILL GAIN BETTER
ACCESS TO CHINA'S MARKET.
IF CHINA GAINS NO NEW MARKET TO
UNITED STATES, WE WILL GAIN
TOUGH NEW SAFEGUARDS AGAINST
SURGES OF IMPORTS AND MAINTAIN
THE STRONGEST POSSIBLE RULES
AGAINST DUMPING PRODUCTS THAT
HAVE HURT AMERICANS IN THE PAST.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOSH.
[LAUGHS]
RHODES SCHOLAR, YALE UNDERGRAD,
YALE LAW SCHOOL, AND LIKE MANY
OTHERS, HE DIDN'T SEE THE
OBVIOUS COMING.
CHINA HAS MANIPULATED AND
DISTORTED WORLD MARKETS, ENGAGED
IN BLATANT RANSACKING OF OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTIES, AND
DUMPED HEAVILY SUBSIDIZE
PRODUCTS INTO THE UNITED STATES,
LEADING TO THE LOSS OF MILLIONS
OF U.S. JOBS.
THE CEO OF MINNESOTA'S CAMBRIA,
IT MAKES COUNTERTOPS, TOLD US
EARLIER THIS WEEK HOW CHINA
TARGETS U.S. MANUFACTURERS FOR
THE SOLE PURPOSE OF DESTROYING
THEM.
AND THEN, DOMINATING THE MARKET.
>> THEY ARE SUBSIDIZED BY THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
THE PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC OF CHINA
IS NOT A FRIENDLY PARTICIPATE IN
A FREE ENTERPRISE ECONOMY IN
AMERICA.
THEY SUBSIDIZE THEIR COMPANIES,
THEY RUN THEIR BANKS, THEY ARE
STATE-OWNED.
AND THEY ARE GOING AFTER
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING.
>> Laura: BUT NO WORRIES
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS.
NOW REMEMBER PRESIDENT OBAMA
SHARING US, BY THE WAY, THAT HIS
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TE
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TT
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TA
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TD
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TT
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TE
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TB
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TI
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TH
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TE
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH TT
CABINET WOULD BE STAFFED WITH T?
>> WE ARE ON TRACK TO FLIP THE
SWITCH IN OCTOBER FIRST.
>> WE ARE ON TRACK TO HAVE THE
MARKETPLACE UP AND RUNNING ON
OCTOBER 1ST, AND CONFIDENT THAT
WE WILL BE UP AND RUNNING AND ON
TRACK ON OCTOBER 1ST.
>> NOBODY SAYS THE SITE IS
WORKING THE WAY WE WANT TO DO.
CERTAINLY THE PRESIDENT
ACKNOWLEDGE YESTERDAY, NO ONE
COULD BE MORE FRUSTRATED AND I
AM, AND THE PRESIDENT, THAT
THIS ISN'T SMOOTH.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT,
$120 MILLION OR SO, WRITE, TO
GET THAT WEBSITE, WAS IT MORE?
AND THEY COULDN'T GET A WEBSITE
WORKING.
LIKE A FRESHMAN AT MIT COULD GET
THE WEBSITE WORKING.
WHO CAN FORGET THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S FOREIGN POLICY
FLOPS?
AGAIN, THESE ARE THE SMART
PEOPLE, REMEMBER.
MAZIE HIRONO SAID WE ARE TOO
SMART FOR OUR OWN GOOD.
REMEMBER WHEN HE DESIGNATED THE
MUSLIM BROTHERHOOD IS MODERATE
ISLAMIST NG EGYPT NT CALLED
IRAN'S PRESIDENT A MODERATE
REFORMER?
>> WE ARE ENCOURAGED THAT
PRESIDENT ROUHANI RECEIVED FROM
FROM THE IRANIAN PEOPLE A
MANDATE TO PURSUE A MORE
MODERATE COURSE.
THEIR COMMITMENT TO GO TO A
DIFFERENT COURSE WILL BE GOOD
FOR THE REGION IN THE WORLD.
>> Laura: IT'S BEEN AWESOME SO
FAR.
HOW ABOUT ALL THE GEOPOLITICAL
GENIUSES THAT HILLARY'S
STATE DEPARTMENT, ALLOWING OUR
AMBASSADOR TO TRAVEL TO BENGHAZI
WHEN WE KNEW ABOUT ATTRIBUTED
SECURITY THREATS AND AN UNSTABLE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND?
HE AND THREE OTHERS ENDED UP
DEAD.
TRUMP REMOVED THE ROSE-COLORED
GLASSES AND WHAT HE DID HIS HE
CONFRONTED THE ROGUE POWERS IN
THE REGION AS THEY EXIST.
TRUMP'S FOREIGN POLICY IS MORE
PRAGMATIC AND PRUDENT.
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE IN
NATION-BUILDING, NOR DOES HE
BELIEVE PASSIVITY IS THE ANSWER
IN THE FACE OF REAL THREATS.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS, THEY FEEL
LIKE, COME ON, THEY HAVE WITH
THE WIND AT THEIR BACKS NOW.
FORGET ALL THE STUFF THAT
HAPPENED, THERE PREDICTIONS
THAT -- IF THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
BE TRUE AT ALL.
BUT THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE A
HEAD OF STEAM, AND YOU CAN KIND
OF UNDERSTAND THAT.
THEY PICKED UP 40 SEATS IN THE
HOUSE.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WHAT I'M SEEING,
THERE IS VERY LITTLE EVIDENCE
THAT THEY HAVE LEARNED MUCH
ABOUT AMERICA.
WHY THEY VOTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE FOR DONALD TRUMP, AND WHY
THEY STILL SUPPORT SO MANY OF
HIS POLICIES, ESPECIALLY ON
TRADE AND IMMIGRATION, AND FORCE
ALL THE DEMOCRATS IN OUR POWER,
THEY COULDN'T WIN THE BIG RACES
IN FLORIDA, TEXAS, OR GEORGIA.
WHY NOT?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY, IN PART, THEY
HAVE NOT COME TO TERMS WITH THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE DECADES OF
ERRORS PAVE THE WAY FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS, AS LEE
SENATOR CLAIRE McCASKILL, OF
COURSE SHE LOST HER REELECTION
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDS
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDM
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDT
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDI
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDG
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNED,
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDT
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDL
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDI
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDG
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDN
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNEDR
BID, SHE SEEMED TO HAVE LEARNED,
"I DON'T THINK MY VOTE AGAINST
BRETT KAVANAUGH HURT ME AS MUCHA
SPECTACLE THAT OCCURRED.
THERE WERE MISTAKES MADE BY MY
PARTY IN TERMS OF HOW THAT WAS
HANDLED."
I'LL SAY.
THE BRIGHT LIGHTS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THOUGH, THEY
DOUBT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WOULD
RALLY BEHIND THEM.
AND THEY SET ABOUT TO DESTROY
THE LIFE OF A MAN WHO ACTUALLY
IS BRILLIANT AND ONE OF THE
FINEST JUDGES IN AMERICA.
WELL, INSTEAD, MOST FAIR-MINDED
PEOPLE, MAYBE THEY DIDN'T GO TO
YALE LAW SCHOOL, THEY SAW THE
CAMPAIGN OF THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
CAMPAIGN A PERSONAL DISTRACTION,
FOR WHAT IT WAS.
INSIDIOUS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NEXT TWO
YEARS IS GOING TO BRING.
BUT BEFORE USE BUT THE WARNINGS
OF THE EXPERT CLASS,